you can only stay on the sidelines for
so long these are unprecedented times
and it seems like every day the rule of
law is being eroded little by little and
frankly I'm sick of it so I'm going to
do something about it I'm suing the
White House the CIA the Department of
Justice and a whole bunch of others this
is not a joke this is actually happening
let me give you some background you
might recall that back in January
President Trump was impeached and he was
facing a trial in the Senate article one
is adopted and one of the people that
seemed to have a lot to say about the
particular charges that were levied
against the president was former
national security adviser john bolton
and in what can only be described as an
act of pure cowardice john bolton
refused to testify before the senate and
instead decided to write a book with his
observations and presumably the things
that he would have testified to at the
senate trial of the president I didn't
think the Democrats had the wit or the
political understanding or the reach now
that's problematic for a whole host of
legal and moral reasons but one of the
legal issues is that as a former
national security adviser in order to
publish a book Boulton had to go through
an onerous pre-publication review
process during the course of that review
process the government would likely take
out a whole bunch of information that it
doesn't want to be published and I
didn't trust the government to do that
pre-publication review and censoring of
John Bolton's book in good faith under
normal circumstances but doubly so when
we're talking about things that strike
at the heart of our democracy and the
president's impeachment trial so back in
February I filed some FOIA requests
against the National Security Council
the CIA the Department of Defense the
Department of Justice the Department of
State basically anyone that would have
possibly gotten a copy of John Bolton's
book and had something to say about it
now normally under this review process
the government can simply say that this
portion of the book is classified and
therefore it cannot be published and
there's some back-and-forth but there's
nothing that forces the government to
really provide reasoning for
or the demands that they're making and
in some circumstances the government
doesn't even need to claim that the
things are classified just that they are
prohibited from being disclosed so who
knows what they prevented Bolton from
saying so the point of legal eagles FOIA
requests was to obtain or at least force
the government to properly process these
redactions under FOIA information that
the government was attempting to prevent
john bolton from publishing in his book
and we also sought to obtain information
about what process the government was
using were there any political
considerations in terms of preventing
john bolton from saying certain things
and did the government prevent him from
saying unclassified information that he
had a right to say because it was
politically damaging not surprisingly
the government has stonewalled our FOIA
requests so we're filing suit we are
suing the government the White House the
CIA the Department of Justice the
Department of Defense the Department of
State and a whole host of other federal
government agencies to find out what
they prevented john bolton from saying
the goals are simple to force the
government to disclose the information
that it didn't want john bolton to
disclose to the public to either force
them to unclassified information to
admit that it was never classified in
the first place and at the bare minimum
to force them to explain why and how
that information is classified and why
it cannot see the light of day this is
actually what happened when Jason
Leopold of BuzzFeed filed a FOIA request
and eventually a lawsuit to enforce that
FOIA request for the original Moeller
report we got a lot more information
about the vague redactions that the DOJ
had actually done to the initial release
of the Moller report and we found out
that a lot of those redactions were
completely improper and because I don't
necessarily trust the government to have
conducted a good-faith investigation in
this particular case we also want the
correspondents know who was making this
decision why these decisions were made
and as I covered in my other video on
the whole john bolton case the timeline
doesn't line up here because allegedly
one of the government employees cleared
john Bolton's entire book for
publication
to have that decision changed at the
last minute
by a political appointee a political
appointee who had basically zero
training in terms of over-classification
it's entirely possible that this whole
process is rife with political
machinations designed to hide the White
House from unflattering information that
should see the light of day so because
the government has stonewalled our
requests we're filing suit we're going
to ask a federal judge to enforce our
demands to make sure that the government
complies with them and to disclose this
information this is not a stunt this is
not a joke we are actually filing a
federal lawsuit to enforce our FOIA
requests as we are entitled to do and
like any good lawyer I have teamed up
with some of the best national security
lawyers in the country specifically in
this case I am working with the National
Security Council errs which is a
nonprofit organization and their
executive director Kel McClanahan who
has more experience with FOIA requests
and FOIA litigation than probably anyone
else and we're committed to taking this
to the mat we want people to be actively
engaged and we want people to have the
information that is important about
their government democracy only works
when the people are informed and have
access to the information that is
critically important and if the Senate
isn't going to give the president a fair
trial when it comes to impeachment then
the only check on executive power is at
the ballot box the primary way that we
reign presidents in is not through
impeachment it's through elections and
that only works when people have the
necessary information including the
information that the government doesn't
want its citizens to have so this will
be the first in a series of videos that
chronicles the adventures of suing the
federal government to disclose
information that probably should have
been disclosed in the first place this
would not be possible without the help
of the National Security Council errs
there's a link in the description to be
able to donate to the National Security
Council arrggh which is a 501 C 3 so
your donation is tax deductible and it
would mean the world to us if you would
consider donating to the cause because
lawyers and litigation are expensive and
we
committed to taking this thing as far as
it needs to go because we believe that
this cause is just
and no one else is going to do it and
any donations made above the cost of
this litigation will go towards the
other charitable work that the National
Security Council errs do which includes
but isn't limited to representing
whistleblowers representing journalists
and FOIA requests suing to strike down
anti transparency policies and practices
and advocating for pro transparency and
accountability reforms in the law and
the government and it'd be great if this
was not a one-time thing I'm hopeful
that this lawsuit will create real and
lasting change or at least be able to
disseminate important information
related to the heart of our democracy
but it would also be great to be able to
write other in justices and to be able
to uphold the rule of law in other
contexts so I'm hopeful that this won't
be a one-off thing and that legal eagle
can create some law not just explain it
so to you legal eagles I thank you for
your support and until next time I'll
see you in court
this time literally